you know that the first person
outside um of me to get a look
at geometric unity was jeffrey epstein
how did he know i was working on this i
don't know
so your ideas that formed geometric
community was something that uh his eyes
have seen
i was pushed to talk to jeffrey epstein
as one of the only people who could help
me
no no listen to this how does this yeah
how does this connect okay
well first of all my old
synagogue my old shule was the
conservative minion at harvard hillel
and i believe it's called rusofsky hall
after henry russovsky in the economics
department who was a japan scholar if
i'm correct
and he became provost or dean of harvard
i believe that that was built with
jeffrey epstein's money
and i wondered in part whether the
jewish students
at harvard all sort of passed through a
bottleneck of harvard hilla
so that was something i found very
curious but i don't know much about it
i also found that jeffrey epstein
hanging around scientists i don't think
that either you or joe exactly
i mean got me correct uh in your
last interchange uh for the record for
people who haven't listened to joe rogan
program joe has claimed that eric
weinstein was the only person who has
gotten laid paid
oh paid and you said you also got paid
as a young man
right i believe the word was laid but uh
allegedly
my hearing isn't so good at age 55. yeah
all right leaving that aside
yes um what was jeffrey epstein doing
hanging around all of these scientists i
don't think that was the same program
that was about compromising political
leaders and business people and
entertainment figures
i think these are two different programs
that were being run through one
individual
and joe seemed to think that i didn't
think he was smooth
i thought he was glib i think what joe
is really trying to get out of his is
that i found his
mysticism meretricious he had a ability
to deflect
every conversation that might go
towards revealing that he didn't know
what he was talking about every time you
started to get close
to something where the rubber hit the
road the rubber wouldn't hit the road
and yet can you help me untangle the the
fact that you thought
deeply about the physics of the nature
of our universe and jeffrey epstein
was interested how did he know i wasn't
really talking about this stuff until
you know even my close friends didn't
really know what i was up to
and yet you're saying he he did not have
sufficient brilliance to understand when
the rubber hit the road so
why why did he have sufficient
interest and tell you what i thought
i've been waiting to find out does my
government even know i exist
do you have an answer to that question i
have
a couple times the government has
reached out to me
in general there is zero interest in me
like less than zero interest
i find that fascinating as far as you
know right
i mean well that's what i'm trying to
say the question about not being able to
see through a half-silvered mirror
you don't know what's going on behind
the half-silvered mirror to you it's
it's all you see is uh is your
reflection
but your intuition still holds like this
is where i mentioned that i
uh this is where i'll say naive dumb
things but i still
hold on to this intuition that jeff
not i'm not confident in this but i i'm
leaning towards that direction that
jeffrey epstein is the source of evil
not something that's
underlying him you have you have a bias
it's different than mine our bayesian
priors
are tutored by different life
experiences
if i was mostly concerned like sam
harris was
is concerned that people fill their
heads with nonsense
i would have a very strong sense that
people need order in the world
that they take mysterious situations
they build entire castles in the air and
then they go move in if they
really get crazy you know the old saying
is that neurotics
build castles in the air and psychotics
move in coming from a progressive family
we had a different experience it's
really weird when the government is
actually out to get you
when they actually send a spy when they
actually engage in disinformation
campaigns when they smear you
and if you've ever had that brought to
bear on your family you have a howard
zinn
sort of understanding of the country
which is different than having
a wow do people believe crazy stuff
because they watch too much tv
and both of these things have some merit
to them but it's a question of regulated
expression when do you want to express
more sam harris and when do you want to
express more howard zinn
and you can express both correct the one
human being can express both
sure but there's a trade-off between
them in other words most of
most people like the michael shermers of
the world are going to tilt very
strongly to
extraordinary claims require
extraordinary evidence you're gonna have
that kind of energy
and then somebody else is gonna say how
many times do i have to get hit on uh
you know how many times i have to hammer
my own thumb before i realize that
there's a problem
so you know my feeling about this is yes
people
see patterns in clouds they see faces
and scripture and all sorts of things
and it's just random cloud patterns
and it's also the case that there's
tremendous pressure
not to see conspiracies when
conspiracies are relatively more common
than the people who shout conspiracy
theory will claim
so both of these things are true and you
have to ask when do you express your
inner
zen and when you're in a harris and
those are different
one fundamental difference in you and i
biases aside
is you've actually met jeffrey epstein
and i'm
uh listening to like reverberations
years later
of stories and narratives throughout the
story luckily i only met him once
and i i think i had one or perhaps two
phone
conversations with him other than the
one meeting you can learn a lot
in just a few words right from a human
being well that's true but i think that
the bigger issue was i saw something
that i don't hear much remarked upon
which is
jeffrey epstein is all there that there
is
in other words there's the national
science foundation national institute of
health howard hughes
there's all this stuff
that kind of has the same feel to it a
little bit of variation and difference
department of energy if you fall outside
of that
there's just jeffrey epstein that's what
you're told yes that's not quite true
there's kavli maybe jim simons is now in
the game
peter thiel has done some stuff you had
yuri milner and
mark zuckerberg try so there is other
money running around
templeton but very strongly there was a
belief
that if you're doing something really
innovative and the system can't fund it
because it's
we've become [ __ ] jeffrey epstein's
your guy
because this funnel that you're supposed
to go through
that's right and the idea is that you
get called to the great man's house
and you know the sort of uh
lubricious version of ralph lauren
you know takes you in and asks you
bizarre questions and maybe he has an
island maybe he has a plane
and you know when you're starved
uh you know somebody showing you a feast
or when you're
dehydrated in a death's door and
somebody says oh
you know i have a well
you know that's what it is and so the
thought is wow
can you can somebody get some effing
money into the science system so that we
don't have
super creeps uh trying to learn all of
our secrets ahead of time
wtf what is your problem with
transparency in taxpayer dollars just
all of you you wouldn't have a country
you'd be speaking german
so essentially you believe that human
beings would not be able to
in the when the money is lacking in the
system like on research
produce public goods you and i are meant
to produce public goods
now i sell athletic greens and i sell
theragan
and i sell unagi scooters and chili pad
can i be honest i love these products
but
i didn't get into this game for the
purpose of selling
i'm trying to figure out how do you have
an
fu lifestyle
you